we start today with a stunning speech
from President Joe Biden last night
defending democracy Joe Biden had to
give a speech saying democracy is a good
thing and we should work to keep it and
we should fight against the people that
want to destroy it and to want to tear
it down imagine that imagine a situation
in 2022 almost 2023 United States where
we have a movement in the country so
unhinged but also so powerful not
overwhelmingly powerful they didn't
succeed in 2020 but they didn't come
that far let's be honest a movement
powerful enough in its extremism and
unhinged nature
that the current president on the
proverbial Eve not the literal Eve but
the proverbial Eve of the 2022 midterms
a president who won even though they say
he lost by the way had to come out and
defend democracy and argue we shouldn't
become violent to overthrow democracy
that's a bad thing
it is a disgusting reality that we have
to face that this is where we are in
almost 2023. let's start with Joe Biden
very clearly talking about what is the
origin of this problem
you know American democracy under attack
because
the defeated former president of the
United States refused to accept the
results of the 2020 election
he refuses to accept the will of the
people
he refuses to accept the fact that he
lost
he has abused his power and put the
loyalty to himself before lord of the
Constitution
and he's made a big lie
an article of faith in the Maga
Republican party indeed the minority of
that party the great irony about half of
the party let's be fair
about the 220 election
is that it's the most attacked election
in our history and yet and yet
there's no election in our history
that we can be more certain of its
results yeah we can be completely sure
that Joe Biden genuinely won and Joe
Biden not only putting the blame and the
responsibility squarely on Trump and
Maga but also pointing out that this is
an extremely consequential midterm
election which is something I've been
saying at this point for a year or
longer I know there's a lot of stake in
these midterm elections from our economy
the safety of our streets to our
personal freedoms the future of Health
Care Social Security Medicare it's all
important
but we'll have our differences we have
our difference of opinion
and that's what it's supposed to be
but there's something else at stake
right democracy itself
I'm not the only one who sees it
recent polls have shown that
overwhelming majority of Americans
believe our democracy at RIS is at risk
that our democracy is under threat
they too see that democracy is on the
ballot this year these are the types of
speeches that often
opposition leaders give
in dictatorships okay
it is out of this world cuckoo that this
is the type of speech that Joe Biden
finds himself giving and he could the
we're going to get to how the right wing
was triggered by this speech he made
clear even when it comes to January 6th
that was not the end of the assault on
democracy and as you know if you've been
following this show there are dozens if
not more Republicans running right now
on the ballot
who deny the results of the election
look even as I speak here tonight
27 million people have already cast
their ballot
in the midterm elections
Millions more will cast their ballots in
the final days leading up to November
the 9th 8th excuse me
and for the first time
this is the first time since the
national election of 2020.
once again we're seeing record turnout
all over the country
and that's good
we want Americans to vote
we want every American's voice to be
heard
now we have to move the process forward
we know that more and more ballots are
cast in early voting or by mail in
America
and we know
that many states don't start counting
those ballots so after the polls close
on November 8th
that means in some cases we won't know
the winner of the election
for a few days until after a few days
after the election
takes time to count all legitimate
ballots
an illegal and orderly manner
it's always been important for Citizens
and democracy to be informed and engaged
now it's important for citizen to be
patient as well
that's how it's supposed to work
this is also the first election since
the events of January 6th
when the armed angry mob stormed the U.S
Capitol
I wish I wish I could say the assault on
a democracy it ended that day it didn't
but I cannot
as I stand here today there are
candidates running for every level of
office in America for governor Congress
Attorney General Secretary of State
who won't commit that will not commit to
accepting the results of the election
that they're running in in fact they're
saying if I lose it's rigged if I win
it's fair Joe Biden also addressing the
rise in the number of people who are
saying violence to achieve your
political goals is okay
we have to be honest with ourselves
though
we have to face this problem
we can't turn away from it
can't pretend it's just going to solve
itself
there's an alarming rise in the number
of our people
in this country condoning political
violence yeah or simply remaining
silence because silence is complicity
the disturbing rise of voter
intimidation
the pernicious tendency to excuse
political violence or at least at least
trying to explain it away
we can't allow this sentiment to grow
we must confront it head on now
it has to stop now
I believe the voices
excusing are calling for violence and
intimidation are distinct minority in
America I do not know well a minority in
America let's hope so a minority in the
Republican party I'm not quite sure and
unfortunately many of the people
minimizing the January 6 Trump riots
uh uh not necessarily welcoming but
certainly inspiring the uh perceived
legitimacy of political violence in the
minds of their supporters
many of them could win and some of them
probably will uh President Biden going
on to connect Trump's big lie
on the attack on Paul Pelosi and they
are connected and all this happened
after the assault
and it's just I if I try hard to even
say
it's hard to even say after the
assailant entered the home asking
where's Nancy
where's Nancy
those are the very same words used by
the mob when they storm the United
States capital on January the 6th
literally when they broke windows
kicked in the doors
brutally attacked law enforcement roam
the Carters hunting for officials
and erected Gallows to hang the former
vice president Mike Pence
it was an enraged model
that had been whipped up into a frenzy
by a president repeating over and over
again
the big lie
that the election of 2020 had been
stolen it is indeed the exact same line
that you follow through those phenomena
Joe Biden warning ahead of time as I
mentioned before that it will take some
time to count all of the legitimate
ballots and that that's okay and then
eventually Biden closing by saying uh
the following year we're often not faced
with questions of whether the vote we
cash will preserve democracy or put us
at risk
but this year we are
this year
I hope you'll make the future of our
democracy an important part of your
decision to vote and how you vote
I hope you'll ask a simple question of
each candidate you might vote for
will that person accept a legitimate
will of the American people of people
voting in his district or her District
yeah it's shocking that that's the Top
Line question we have to ask they're a
group there you've got the candidates
who have their policy and they will
accept the results of the election and
then you've got the candidates that will
not that's a major dividing line who
respects the will of the voter here
will that person accept the outcome of
the election win or lose
the answer to that question is vital
and in my opinion it should be decisive
and the answer to that question
hangs the future of the country we love
so much and the fate of the democracy
has made so much possible for us yeah uh
a good speech
a really dystopian reality in which such
a speech is necessary and logical so Joe
Biden did a few important things here
other than defend the idea that we
thought we had a democracy we should
probably work to try to keep that he
issued a sort of warning about
Republicans planning to undermine the
vote on Tuesday and we're going to have
Clips later on and on tomorrow's show of
ways in which they are already doing
this and other examples so the
Republicans are already doing that
they're making it clear they're
telegraphing they're going to be doing
that on Tuesday Joe Biden sort of trying
to sound the alarm in advance the way we
were doing and many in Progressive media
were doing in advance of the 2020
election it was very clear what Trump
was going to do
and at two something in the morning on
Election night 2020 he did he came out
and said oh I won even though he had not
won and then the other thing is he's
setting expectations about it'll take a
few days in some of these elections to
know the results particularly because in
some of these places they don't actually
start counting anything until the polls
close there will be a whole but
Pennsylvania is an example actually I
don't remember if Pennsylvania doesn't
start until a polls close but they stop
at a particular time a whole bunch of
accumulated mail-in and early ballots
will be there but they will not start to
be counted until post close in many
cases at 8 pm local time so an important
speech very sad that he had to make it
let's now look at the reactions from the
right Fox News was trigly triggered into
being a sputtering Mess by Joe Biden's
speech last night saying hey we should
try to maintain our democracy
and Republicans running in November
running now in 2022 are increasingly
threatening to upend it if they lose if
I lose it was rigged if I won then it's
fair Joe Biden with a very good speech
which we already looked at take a look
at some of the reactions from
Republicans each I don't know whether
they call these sad whether they're
called these dangerous whether to to
call them delusional maybe it's a
combination let's look at them here's
Kevin McCarthy the House minority leader
reacting to Joe Biden's speech about
democracy being in danger that was the
announced subject matter we knew the
speech was going to be about democracy
and Kevin McCarthy says well it was a
bad speech because he didn't mention
inflation or gas prices I listened to
the president's speech I don't remember
hearing anything about inflation about
gas about border about fentanyl about
crime or not even the 98 individuals On
the Border who are on the terrorist
watch list they have caught what we're
really finding in these next six days
this is a hinge election this is this is
defining election like a 1980 election
which direction does America want to go
that's why we have the commitment to
America we literally spell out what
we'll do it's holding up a piece of
paper when he says that because energy
independent gives an economy that's
strong secure the Border fund the police
stop the prosecutors who are woke give
you a parent's Bill of Rights understand
that all of those things I mean the
economy at least for now is fine we have
almost full employment GDP growth is
back nothing has materially changed on
the border since Trump you know all
these things are completely made up but
the critique is he didn't talk about
inflation and gas prices the speech was
about democracy because Kevin McCarthy
and the cronies in his party and their
constituents seem not to care about
democracy anymore that's why the subject
matter was what it was in reaction to
Joe Biden's speech Jesse Waters Another
Beauty on Fox News
says this is all nonsense because we're
just gonna win there's not gonna be
anything to deny that was the president
United States confessing that he's about
to get wiped out a week from now
no one is going to question the results
of this election Mr President because
it's going to be a blowout Now
understand
Jesse thinks he's being clever he thinks
he's being clever by saying you're not
going to have any questioning
because we're going to win there's not
going to be anything to question but
he's actually proving exactly the point
that Joe Biden made which is they don't
question it when they win and they
question it when they lose a priori
saying losses are fraud we'll talk later
about what a priori means uh he seems to
actually be proving Joe Biden's point
now is it true that Democrats are going
to get wiped out maybe we talked about
new polling at the same time there are
growing concerns that the new polling is
very bad polling we're going to find out
in you know what is it five days
we'll know before you know it just make
sure you take your vote and use it one
other clip here's Republican senator
Lindsey Graham also uh talking about Joe
Biden's speech and saying he didn't even
mention the Border well no it wasn't
about the Border Stacy Abrams herself
but that's not happening either uh what
was your reaction to Biden's angry
speech
by the way it's logical to be angry when
one side doesn't care about democracy uh
if I'm a liberal Democrat I would say
Joe please stop helping I thought it was
pathetic I thought it was divisive not
one word about how I'm going to secure a
broken border how I'm going to lower gas
prices as president how I'm going to
challenge rampant crime what's funny is
he already lowered gas prices as
president the Synergy independent it was
if you believe the president has
anything to do with it by the way which
I don't but again this is their story
it's about half the country uh basically
being a political terrorist yeah it's
not half the country that are political
terrorists but it's a non-zero portion
of the Republican party and we're seeing
it day to day these folks are pathetic
these folks are pathetic and they are
openly subscribing to
if we win it was fair
and if we lose it was rigged let me know
your thoughts in a comment or find me on
Twitter at dpacman remember we are
pushing to 2 million YouTube subscribers
many of you out there maybe I'm talking
about you you watch our clips on YouTube
but you're not subscribed do us the
favor of subscribing even if you're
seeing our videos in your feed because
it is the most important signal to
YouTube's algorithm hey maybe I should
recommend this guy's content
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
remember that the David packman show is
made possible by our viewers by our
listeners that is the primary source of
funding for our show and I would love
for you to sign up at
joinpakman.com where you will get
instant access to the commercial free
audio and video streams of the show as
well as the bonus show that is a
freaking Predator right there no it's
not predatory Alex it's just it's just
the bonus show through Tuesday through
election day you can use the coupon code
big voting22 to secure a perfect
discount let's take a a spin through the
campaign Trail and the last 24 hours a
number of former democratic presidents
out on the campaign Trail hoping to uh
stem losses hoping to create wins hoping
to turn maybe at least a couple of
Elections one of those individuals is
former president Barack Obama former
president Barack Obama really stung
Kerry Lake and by extension Donald Trump
by pointing out we've tried electing
people who are just known for being on
TV and it didn't go particularly well
reports are many on the right
particularly upset by what Barack Obama
said yesterday during an event in
Arizona in support of Democrats running
in that state yeah
[Music]
a question that that Katie hobbs's
opponent she's good in front of the
camera because she's been doing it for a
long time right so some people don't
know this but uh apparently Kerry Lake
actually interviewed me back in 2016
when I was President true she was a she
was a local news anchor she was doing
her job at the time
I don't remember thinking that she was
the kind of person who would push
debunked covid remedies or promise to
issue a declaration of invasion at our
border that's a very important action or
a claim without any evidence
that the 2020 election was stolen I
guess that stuff came later because she
found it convenient because she thought
well here's an opportunity to get
attention yep
listen it if we hadn't just elected
somebody whose main qualification was
being on TV
you could see maybe giving it a shot
what's the Worst That Could Happen well
now we know yeah it doesn't just work
out just because somebody's been on TV
uh President Obama is uh is is quite
good at this and indeed he is needed in
Arizona and the reason that he is needed
in Arizona is just look at the polling
Kerry lake is an individual who has no
business whatsoever in public service
she talked about Arizona
seceding from the United States she
spreads the big lie she said she was
taking prophylactic Ivermectin on and on
and on and she is I don't even want to
say potentially I think at this point we
have to say if you believe the polling
she is the most likely Heir Apparent to
become the governor of Arizona currently
Kerry lake is leading Democrat Katie
Hobbs by an average of 2.8
now
what's going on with the polling do we
believe these numbers I don't know we
will have a report either tomorrow or
Monday about the allegations of bad
polling unreliable polling and push
polling related to the election
but why chance it why Chance it 2.8
maybe she's winning by 2.8 maybe it's a
tie or not your vote really matters this
time around and for everybody who says
well what do you mean my vote it's never
it never comes down to one vote here's
the the way you have to think about that
how often does the election come down to
one vote very rarely
but a lot of people say that to
themselves a lot of people say
why do I need to vote it never comes
down to one vote
if all the people who thought that
stayed home it would actually flip
elections and that's why it's important
when you say to yourself it never comes
down to one vote why do I need to vote
understand that there are thousands or
tens of thousands or hundreds of
thousands of other people saying the
same thing to themselves if you all stay
home one candidate wins if everybody who
has that thought votes the other
candidate wins so do not allow yourself
to fall into that thinking one other
funny Barack Obama clip from the Arizona
rally talking about Blake Masters that
really bizarre dude who's running
against Mark Kelly and also who might
win just very funny commentary about him
if you were trying to create
in a lab yes
a wacky Republican politician
it'd look a lot like this guy
Mr Masters true
campaign backed by a tech billionaire
who's questioned the value of democracy
right check
got it wants to give test us to Big
corporations that are jacking up prices
on consumers of course check
thinks it's a good idea to privatize
Social Security and quote cut the knot
on the benefits
that more than a million seniors here in
Arizona depend on
check check check
[Applause]
I I got a little fired up about this the
other day in Wisconsin but it's true
here in Arizona too
Folsom Arizona have social security not
because somebody's giving it to him as a
payoff as a as a gift they earned it for
it that's exactly right and the social
security issue is increasingly becoming
an issue very good appearance by former
president Barack Obama he was not the
only former president out on the
campaign trail yesterday former
President Bill Clinton appeared at a
campaign event for a Josh Riley a
Democrat running for the New York house
and it's less this showing you this clip
is less about Josh Riley it's more about
Bill Clinton perfectly summing up modern
era Republicans I'll just play the clip
and then we'll talk about it the
Republicans are pretty simple actually
they're and pretty straightforward they
say
I want you to be very miserable
and I want you to be very angry
and I vote I want you to vote for us
and we'll make it worse but we'll blame
them yeah
[Applause]
that is exactly what the modern
Republican party is they don't propose
policy they don't bring any big ideas of
any value or substance let's think
through an example think about the
economy right now Republicans are saying
the economy is bad right now the economy
is bad right now that's not true the
economy is actually pretty solid right
now by all standard economic indicators
is inflation High yes but we're at
almost full employment GDP growth is
back stock market is
shaky but not a disaster we have all the
data so they lie by saying the economy
is currently bad
they say Democrats are terrible for the
economy and we'll make it better vote
for us the truth is historically
Democrats are better for the economy
historically we have higher job growth
when there's a Democratic president
stock market performs better under a
Democratic president we have lower
unemployment under a Democratic
president GDP growth is higher under a
Democratic president inflation is lower
under a Democratic president on average
okay
so then you elect them they don't make
it any better because they're worse for
the economy we know that
but when it gets worse they'll say well
it's the fault of Democrats if they
control the Senate and the White House
and the economy doesn't do as well as
they claim it should have done they will
say well even though we had the White
House in the Senate the economy didn't
do so well because Democrats controlled
the house it is spot on spot on analysis
from Bill Clinton here and they've
abandoned policy as I've told you many
times before and it's these cultural
issues these contrived issues of
wokeness and litter boxes and in fact
that's exactly what I want to talk about
next I don't want to spend a ton of time
on this but I have an example for you of
what happens when you confront one of
these right-wing Republicans who repeats
fake stories one such fake story is
schools are putting litter boxes in the
bathrooms so that students who identify
as animals can use the litter box as
their bathroom
it's made up
didn't happen it has been repeated and
repeated and repeated but it did not
happen Don balduck who's running in New
Hampshire was confronted about it why
did you say that that's just not true
and he says well it's what I was told
you made it a recent event about
children using litter boxes in schools
you know there's no that's not what I
said okay well then tell me what you
said I heard the audio so what yeah so
uh what I was talking about is all the
craziness going on in our schools and
this is just one of them and I had a I
had a parent and a student
in that audience who came up to me and
told me all about it yeah guys listen a
parent and a student if it was only a
parent okay if it was only a student but
a parent and a student told them
students who identify as animals are
going pee pee and poo poo in a litter
box so he started repeating it I've had
that all across the state so I'm only
articulating what I heard from the ice
skaters parents he didn't make it up he
heard it guys children craziness is
going on in our schools Senator Hassen
is responsible for it she's doubled down
occasion policies out there understand
how crazy this is it's not happening in
schools and Maggie Hassan has nothing to
do with it because it's not taking place
so you should be asking her why our
children can't read and write to grade
level why we have the lowest scores why
we can't compete in the world why our
children require remedial courses to go
to college because she has took her eye
off the ball on the future of our nation
and that's our children
you had a parent tell you yes parent and
student happening in the school the
school has come out and said that that's
completely false well you know they they
came out and said they didn't ask
children they came out and said they
didn't do a lot of things right they
don't teach CRT which they do they don't
treat transgender which they do they
teach transgender I'm not backing down
okay he's not backing down from
something that is just not happening and
so you can Google this it's widely
documented there's a good NBC news
article from
um a couple weeks ago how an herb Urban
myth about litter boxes in schools
became a republican talking point at
least 20 Republicans claimed schools are
making accommodations for students who
identify as cats the school districts
say these claims are untrue we would be
able to write this off as an insanely
stupid timeline
if people weren't falling for it
and if people weren't actually being
influenced in their votes based on these
bogus false stories really scary stuff
make sure you're following us on
Instagram at davidpakman show to see all
of the clips that we played today
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show today
we'll be speaking with Saul cassen whose
distinguished professor of psychology at
John Jay College of Criminal Justice in
New York City and also professor
emeritus of psychology at Williams
College in Massachusetts he is author of
the book duped why innocent people
confess and why we believe their
confessions I really appreciate your
time today glad to have you on I'm very
very happy to be here so anecdotally we
all hear stories of Innis innocent
people who confess to crimes they did
not commit I think a natural reaction a
common reaction is to say I would never
do that I can't imagine any
circumstances in which police sit me
down and they suspect me for a crime and
I know I didn't commit it I would never
ever ever confess to a crime I didn't
commit and yet it happens all the time
can you tell us a little bit about why
this happens
you're absolutely right I think the
first myth that has to be debunked is I
would never confess to a crime I did not
commit yeah answer yes you would
and uh you will note that there are two
titles to the title of my book one is
why innocent people confess and two why
we believe their confessions we are
duped into believing false confessions
so when those of us who are presented
with a confession and we're thinking an
innocent person would never do this
we can't see past a false confession it
looks true it sounds true it feels true
I would never do that innocent people
don't do that
wrong
imagine yourself being brought in as a
suspect in a crime you're taken into the
station you're alone you're isolated
you're not with family you're not with
friends if you're a kid you're asking
can I call my mother and the answer is
not till we're done here
and then you come in and the detective
walks in and slaps a folder on the table
and says we know you committed this
crime and we have a boatload of evidence
against you
and that's how that session proceeds
privately without you having any access
to outside sources of information or
people and that goes on sometimes for
hours
until the officer the detective or
detective's plural offers you something
of a way out you know I think you're a
good person I don't think you intended
to do this maybe this was just something
your friends put you up to or or you had
one too many drinks and they start to
make it sound as if the consequence
would be minimal you want out
you believe for whatever reason they
seem to have this overwhelming evidence
against you and you've been denying this
for hours and they keep calling you a
liar every time you deny it
you're trying to get out of the
situation and now they're offering you
an escape hatch the Escape patch is you
know what just cooperate with us we
think we think you're a good person we
don't think you meant to do this
and before you know what you're signing
a statement believing that that
signature and that statement is in your
best interest it sounds like to some
degree you know we've talked with
attorneys about the kind of plea deal
industrial complex and some of the
circumstances including being able to
get out of pre-trial detention including
a known smaller penalty than chancing
the possibility of a much stricter
dependency we've talked about that it
seems that there are some similar
Dynamics between that and false
confessions although they clearly are
two different things and they relate to
the isolation the disproportionate power
that Dynamic that exists and the unknown
of it could be even worse if I stick to
my guns that's exactly right and what a
what a perfect parallel to plea
bargaining that you just described
because they are the same process people
are making what a decision-making
theorist would say is a rational
decision given the information they have
they're trying at this point to cut
their losses and you know what's
interesting about the parallel between
the confession that a suspect gives to
police in an interrogation room and then
the guilty plea confession that they
give in court to prosecutors and defense
lawyers
it's the same Dynamic but here's what's
interesting
people who have confessed to police are
then later more likely to accept the
false guilty plea why because everybody
correctly is telling them if you go to
trial you're going to get convicted
so the confession now gives rise to and
spawns a false guilty plea
and you know I've got a whole chapter in
this book about this system of ours
being obsessed with confession it
happens One More Time Imagine the person
who confesses later pleads guilty is
sitting in prison and is now eligible
for parole and they have to appear
before a parole board well guess what
they can't get out until they accept
responsibility and show they've been
rehabilitated and so I've spoken and
worked on cases of exonerees who
confessed and then said the most galling
next thing I ever had to do in my life
was reconfest years later in order to
become
paroled and once again here's the system
not understanding that the Baseline
level of wrongful conviction it's not
zero guys may have been conceived of a
zero fifty years ago we now know it's
not zero
when there is a confession and the
confession isn't thrown out when it's
thrown out it we can put it in another
category but when there's a confession
that makes it into an eventual trial
um is it overwhelmingly difficult to to
overcome that when when there is an
accepted confession as part of a trial
um once first of all I seldom see
confessions that are suppressed from
evidence yeah they almost always are
admitted these days the question a judge
will ask at a suppression hearing is
well did he wave his Miranda Right did
he did he receive and wave his Miranda
rights yes well then it's a voluntary
statement that's that becomes proof of
voluntariness Miranda is a whole
separate problem yes in this business
um so so now that now the person comes
to court and there's a confession in
evidence
I don't want to overstate it but almost
nothing else matters in the infamous
Central Park jogger case for example
people don't realize this
those kids confessed on videotape they
were induced after 14 to 30 hours of
questioning to confess and only the
confession was on tape not the and just
so people know sometimes this is known
as the Central Park 5 case it's the same
we're talking about the same case yeah
yes and they've all been exonerated
since honorrated
um what people don't realize is after
they confess and before they went to
trial the the jogger was raped and there
was a rape kit and there were several
semen samples and those samples were
sent to the crime lab and when those
samples came back here was the result
all of the different semen samples
traced to a single individual not five
not six one person
and that person was not one of the five
confessors the confessors were excluded
so they come to trial with their
confessions no other supporting
corroborating evidence contradictory DNA
evidence and they were convicted that's
how powerful confession evidence is
almost nothing else matters once that is
in evidence as a general question how
relevant in these situations is some
level of Education as well as the
financial access to a lawyer and the
reason I ask that is in my mind
I would never even go in to talk to
police voluntarily number one if I had
to go in I would absolutely get a lawyer
and if I was arrested and then you know
if it wasn't a situation where they call
and say hey would you like to come in if
I'm arrested and brought in I would say
literally not a word other than I want a
lawyer which seems like it would help me
in in this situation or even when doing
that do you still see false confessions
um man you're asking all the asking all
the right questions
um so myth number one I would never
confess to a crime I didn't commit myth
number two is I'd know a false
confession if I saw one if I sat on a
jury and this was an innocent person I
know it okay wrong would not okay the
third myth is that Miranda protects us
that our Miranda rights matter
um here here's here's one fact that was
discovered within one year of the
Supreme Court's Miranda decision that
roughly 80 percent of people wave their
rights right out of the gate yes and we
now know that that number is holding
steady and higher here's what else we
know you know who's the most likely to
waive their rights
innocent people
when I work on cases involving false
confessors who are later fully DNA
exonerated without dispute their
factually innocent
I asked him two questions one why did
you confess
and the second question is when things
got ugly why don't you call a lawyer why
didn't you stop talking and call a
lawyer
every one of them says the same thing in
almost the same words I didn't need a
lawyer I didn't do anything wrong
innocent people don't understand the
peril
they have some fundamental belief in the
power of their innocence to Prevail they
have some fundamental belief in the
world as a place that is more just than
this
and so they figure you know I'll talk
we'll talk they'll see I didn't do this
very often when the police imply or
outright State we have evidence we've
got prints we're sending off to the lab
now that sounds like a threat we've got
you we've got Prince to the innocent
person imagine yourself innocent and you
know you're innocent they say they've
got Prince you've been here for hours
and you want to get out and you're
thinking Prince that's going to show my
innocence to the innocent person that
threat that bluff of having evidence
is a promise of future exoneration um
and so they think okay I've been here
for 19 hours I can't take it anymore
where do I sign and when the prints come
back you'll see I didn't do this I don't
know the law around you mentioned 19
hours 13 hours 14 hours this is sort of
a an interlude but I I don't know the
law around that but if you ask for a
lawyer right away is a lawyer going to
allow you to be there for 19 hours or
does a lawyer prevent that from even
becoming the situation
a lawyer seldom
people sell the mask for a lawyer right
away and part of it too is and this gets
to some points about Miranda first of
all people don't fully understand their
rights
and you know Miranda is something we
hear we hear it on Law and Order
everybody can recite the words by heart
you know almost almost by memory and yet
uh when you when you measure people's
comprehension of the rights themselves
and how that operate them it's amazing
how little comprehension people have so
for example
um what if you come in and you don't
realize that you're a suspect
um and you think maybe you're a
cooperating witness and you're not sure
that the police are about to fully
accuse you yeah but they read you your
Miranda Rights to say we'd like to talk
to you but we can't really do that until
we get past this formality and so I'd
like to read your rights you've heard
them a million times before but you have
the right to remain silent anything you
say can be used against you
the suspect says yes yes yes I
understand where do I sign and they sign
away that waiver
now
what if things start to get ugly
ask the average person
are you able once you've signed a waiver
of your rights are you able to reinvoke
them later
the answer is yes right A lot of people
don't know the answer is yes so there's
one aspect of comprehension that people
lack people think once they've signed
off on that waiver that's it
and they worry also about the Optics of
Silence
and of course for innocent people they
don't understand the Peril of talking
right and so they do and so the people
that require in some sense the greatest
protection those accused who are
innocent they're not going to use that
protection
and so it tends not to happen now as far
as the time frame you mentioned the
average interrogation only lasts for 30
minutes to an hour and if you want to
Encompass 90 to 95 of all percent of all
interrogations it's a couple of hours
when you look at the database of
wrongful convictions in which people
gave false confessions now you're
looking at eight hours ten hours 16
hours 20 hours
time breaks people down
time breaks people down because we start
to get lonely I don't mean that in a
clinical sense but people need others
around and they need social support
especially when times get stressful yeah
they need someone to check in with they
need breaks they need to get they need
sleep deprivation is accompanied by
these 20-hour sessions
um
food breaks you know so it's both it's
both biological and social needs and
fatigue sets in
I I've worked on cases where I literally
did a count of the number of times the
innocent person said I didn't do this
and was called the liar sometimes that
happens over a hundred times in an
interrogation so if you want out if
you're exhausted if you can't take it
anymore and every time you deny
involvement they call you a liar and you
realize this isn't my way out of here
you've got to try something else last
thing I want to ask about you write in
the book about the Amanda Knox murder
case uh in Italy there's a Netflix
documentary about that and if I recall
generally speaking this is a case in
which Amanda Knox an American was
accused of a murder along with I believe
it's a guy she may have been
romantically involved with of a of a a
third person a woman
um can you talk a little bit about what
happened in that one and how it's
relevant to what you write about
you know it's such a perfect
illustration of something that's so
important to know when people hear that
an innocent person confess knowing as
you opened with I would never do that a
normal person would never do that
everyone's first reaction is what's
wrong with that person yeah that what is
they immediately make an attribution to
something is wrong with that person who
did this they don't think about the
situation that person was in that might
afflict just about anybody Amanda Knox
was a 20 year old American student in
Italy smart smart kid
but she was in Italy she wasn't fluent
in the language and her roommate was
murdered in a vile way and she was the
person who discovered the crime scene
and called it in and over the course of
four days for no good reason she was
identified as a suspect
for no good reason and I I could catalog
the the numbers of demeanor cues oh she
did that she looked like this she looked
like that she didn't cry enough she
cried too much that were used to
identify her as a suspect to the point
where she was interrogated on and off
for four and a half days for over 50
hours
culminating in a final night where they
brought her in
told her that that that romantic that
person she was romantically involved
with who was with her that night that he
disavowed her Alibi that he said he
wasn't with her that night
now it's now five in the morning she's
confused she's been at this for days her
mother like her mother said maybe we
should come and get you and bring you
home and she says no I think I can help
them with this
so she stayed back and had that
phenomenology of Innocence where she
didn't appreciate the Peril she was in
she didn't when I asked her about this
she didn't realize she was a suspect
until the very last moment
and then at five six in the morning they
hand write a confession in Italian and
get her to sign it and she confesses
and then they take another confession a
couple hours later and as soon as she as
soon as she has a little sense of mind
and she's left alone she immediately
realizes oh my God I'm so confused and
she hand writes a recantation of that
confession yes but in the meantime the
Amanda Knox case shows something else
she confesses within two weeks there's
DNA splattered all over the crime scene
they find the guy who did it and he has
a criminal background and he fled to
Germany right after the I mean they they
got the guy
but they would not overturn her
confession and they proceeded to
prosecute her and the boyfriend despite
having DNA all over the place from
another person
by the time she got to trial and this
this tells a lot about confession cases
by the time she got to trial it wasn't
just her confession
her friends turned against her new
Witnesses came out of the woodwork
forensic analysts were misinterpreting
forensic evidence in ways that suggested
her guilt
it illustrates something other some
other point about confessions when
somebody confesses to a crime they
didn't commit all of a sudden it
corrupts that confession once the word
gets out corrupts other Witnesses right
corrupts forensic scientists and so by
the time a Confessor an innocent
Confessor gets into the courtroom
they face a mountain of evidence
which is really nothing but a house of
cards built on a back of a false
confession and that's what happened to
her
she appeared in court and all of a
sudden there's this parade of lying and
non-credible Witnesses and forensic
examiners who are not correctly
interpreting the data and you know her
case has ultimately been resolved
Italy's Supreme Court said so declared
her innocent was critical of the
prosecutor for for the case and to begin
with yeah but but she went through hell
and and part of the reason she went
through hell was the constant surprise
of witness after witness who appeared in
light of her confession yep that that's
a quite a quite a um emblematic story of
exactly what you write about in the book
I'll remind you the book is duped why
innocent people confess and why we
believe their confessions we've been
speaking with the book's author Saul
Cason I really appreciate your time
today
pleasure it's pleasure
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
Fox News did town halls with the Ohio
Senate candidates that's Democrat Tim
Ryan currently a congressman and
Republican candidate JD Vance during the
Tim Ryan portion of the Town Hall Tim
Ryan did not back down from the Fox News
mob and this is really interesting to
see it's it's quite impressive in fact
this seems to be a stacked audience some
maybe Democrats but the Lion's Share of
the noise certainly was not a
pro-democratic that's for sure and Tim
Ryan turned what were initially booze
into at least some cheers on the topic
of January 6. take a look at this listen
to the initial jeers and look at how he
turns it around and we'll talk about
what he does they storm the capital on
January 6th they beat up 140 police
officers killed killed one okay they
killed what they killed one
we all we all we all watched we all
watch the we all watch the video okay so
they boo but here he turns it around
I'll watch a video and I okay
let him finish please and I work I'm
happy to have this conversation I'm not
afraid to have this conversation these
are the conversations we need to have in
this country I welcome you guys let's
just be respectful but I'm not afraid to
stand here and defend my position
um on January 6th 140 cap I I sit on the
subcommittee that funds the Capitol
Police
these are my friends 140 of them got
hurt and some of them still can't go
back to work because they were beat up
with lead pipes they were sprayed with
pepper spray they were beaten with
flagpoles okay they were trying to
overthrow the government they were
trying to stop the peaceful transition
of the government what else were they
doing there are they going to kill Mike
Pence right you want to kill Nancy
Pelosi now somebody's beating up Nancy
Pelosi's husband with a hammer
JD Vance raised money for the
insurrectionist he made several social
media posts to raise money for them now
again I don't care what your politics
are but Americans should say
no we have to say no to that we're going
to try to get as many questions all
right so a smattering of Applause what
turned the tide here for him it's a
couple different things number one Tim
Ryan stood his ground he stood his
ground he said hold on
I'll go up against any of you on the
facts but let's do it respectfully he
backed up what he was saying it helped
that he was telling the truth and then
he found common ground with the audience
and we're going to have I've told you
all before we're very close to releasing
a white paper about how to have
conversations about politics that can be
contentious we're going to give it away
for free we've been working on it for
weeks giving it away soon
um and finding common ground is a really
critical part of this
um one other element to this Tim Ryan
also getting Applause when talking about
uh his answer on energy policy tax that
President Biden mentioned a tax on oil
companies profits are you for that
um I haven't looked at exactly what he
wants to do I think the fact that oil
companies are making huge profits and
having stock BuyBacks right now while
average person here is paying nearly
four dollars a gallon I think that's
wrong and I think we need to crack down
we need to crack down on it
we're going to move on
so I mean listen uh Tim Ryan is not the
most Progressive but he was able to find
common ground with a lot of these folks
and I think that that is instructive in
many ways unfortunately if you believe
the polling JD Vance is now up by about
2.2 points on average the important
message is if you vote in Ohio make damn
sure that you participate in this
election because Tim Ryan could win this
thing Donald Trump's sort of newish
spokeswoman Liz Harrington appeared
yesterday on the water cooler on real
America's voice with this guy David
Brody she was asked to comment about Joe
Biden's speech and also about the
upcoming midterms and this is a
prototypical example this is the
textbook example of a priori reasoning
okay
forget about everything I just said just
let's listen to the clip and then I'll
explain to you what I mean somehow he
thinks he's going to be this last minute
savior for his party at the last moment
with the midterms why is Biden doing
this tonight Liz
you know that's a very good question
because anyone who knows it's not that
great of a question because he's such a
drag on the Democrat Party and any
chance they have which we know they
don't come next Tuesday they don't have
a chance unless they cheat as he
documented very well there's so many
cases already of just irregularities and
misdeeds and that's not true the
evidence of the corruption in our
election process and that's the only
hope that they have because the fact is
Democrats do not like democracy they
don't want the voters to decide they
want to decide for the voters that's not
really the way it went in 2020 is it Liz
and look at how that has worked out
they're destroying the country they've
destroyed our border they've destroyed
the economy they destroyed our energy
Independence all of these things that
were so hard fought by President Donald
J Trump to put America First they're
destroying and the voters know it and
they know they're going to lose come
election day unless they do you know
some of these outrageous things that
they did in 2020 and do it on such a
scale that we've never seen before
because they're going to have to
overcome really this Mammoth Red Wave
that's coming yeah this is Red Alert
stuff folks they're doing it again they
are doing the fascist authoritarian
thing if they win then they must have
cheated Democrats that is a priori now a
priori means reasoning which proceeds
from a theoretical deduction rather than
from observations or experiences so what
does that mean in this context they're
not observing actual cheating
or waiting until election day to see how
the election goes and then if there
really are irregularities or cheating
then you go oh this is what happened
it's theoretical it's in advance absent
any actual data or empirical reality if
they when they cheated regardless of
what we actually observe and of course
they add on to it another classic
authoritarian wrinkle
which is to claim you observed the thing
anyway even though you didn't uh oh
there's already irregularities the
irregularities we're seeing now are for
example armed individuals hanging around
Arizona drop boxes right Wingers trying
to intimidate voters though the only
irregularities we're seeing are from
people on Liz Harrington's side these
folks are disgusting and they're
delusional but they're dangerous and
we've talked about all of the reasons
why and it should really scare the
Daylights out of all of us because what
they tried to do in 2020
they might get close enough in 2022 to
then really be able to do it in 2024.
we'll have all the results but these
folks will say it's rigged if they don't
win and that's really scary we have a
voicemail number and that number is 219
to David P here is a caller I this is
one the guy who calls in his connection
is always very strange it sounds like a
1930s phone connection it's very
interesting he very strongly and
powerfully denounces paywalls and
reminds me to remind you
we produce the show and you can watch it
for free this is a good guy
reason why you slipped up this time and
you forgot to mention when you ask
people to subscribe remind them this is
not something they have to pull put a
pull a credit card out correct they can
go on on their computer and subscribe
and not worry about having a paywall
it's free you forgot to mention that
so I'm reminding you a suggestion maybe
put a sticky notepad
below the monitor or whatever you look
at the camera so that you can read it
and and you can be reminded you can
remind yourself to mention subscriptions
there are no charge that's exactly right
and of course this gentleman is talking
about podcast and YouTube folks we're
giving it away we're giving it away the
entire YouTube show is free you
subscribe free on YouTube the audio
podcast is free now the way we pay for
that is there's advertising and if you
want to get rid of the advertising you
get a membership on my website speaking
of the membership the membership gets
you the bonus show on today's bonus show
we will talk about the FCC commissioner
calling for a tick tock ban
wow we will talk about how predatory
gambling has helped the lottery Reach
This sky-high jackpot that so many
people have written to me about and we
have polling from Pennsylvania which
finds seven percent of Pennsylvania
voters have been dissuaded from voting
for John fetterman because of his stroke
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show sign up at joinpakman.com
thank you